i love that story in your book so much
where what was something you would do
you would call um you would call agent's
office
as uh what was the celebrity that you
used to do well we used to say we were
having a hard time getting agents my
friend eugene pack and i we were out in
l.a for a while we would we would try to
slip our head shots under the door
walking up and down sunset but nobody
was calling and i was like how are we
gonna bust in
this is brilliant so we are david mamet
had taught at class at nyu david mammoth
of playwright glengarry glenn ross we
called it the mammoth scam and what we
did was
we
we thought it to get into asian stores
so i had a fake character named liz
stockwell eugene peck's character was
arnold katz and we would call for one
another pretending to be one another's
you know agents and we would call
whatever agent we wanted to meet i would
say hi this is you know liz stockwell
i'm calling from david mamet's office
we'd like to speak to this agent and
they were like oh my gosh they would put
the agent right on the phone right and
then i would say david speaks so highly
of your company really and you and you
know we have a kid out here who's in
david's next play he's like an uh he's
the up-and-coming star
and you know you gotta meet this kid we
always had a rule doing sales where you
couldn't hang up the phone until you had
the credit card so we used the same
thing with the mammoth scam so it was
like don't hang up the phones you got
the appointment in the books so if this
asia would say well why don't you just
have eugene call me when he gets a ton i
would go no there was an answer for
every obstacle
you know it was a whole thing and we
would crack up you know so
so when you got a meeting with an agent
yeah they they would take these meetings
with you because they felt david mamet
had uh recommended you yeah you were the
up-and-comer oh yes it was like theater
and classy and and we figured they're
getting to meet good talented people so
we figure we're giving them a gift you
know
yeah it's nothing wrong with that i mean
and we did it on friday afternoons when
everybody was in a good mood after four
oh my god but we got busted once
oh you did what happened was one of them
was
you know i wanted to be part of the brat
pack i was like i want to be with those
kids ali sheedy and molly ringwald so it
was a black brat packs agent i got an
appointment for with and when i sat down
with her she was like i just wanted to
see what a liar looked like in person
wow oh my god were you dying i was dying
and i go what what do you mean i i use
my nyu acting skills and she goes
your friend
called and said he works with david
mamet what a liar and i acted like wait
what and she goes wait hold on a second
honey she goes are you dating this guy
and i wasn't dating jane he was just my
friend eugene but i said yeah i just
i've only been dating him for a few
weeks and he he told me he could help me
out in hollywood i just played like i
was a dumb actress and she was like and
then she like sisterly confided in me
like honey this guy's a scum bucket he
doesn't know anyone
and then i left and i i called jean on a
eugene on a payphone i was like we just
got so busted
but oh my god i would die and gene got
me a part on twin peaks i i wanted to be
on twin peaks so he got me on that i
wanted to meet the co casting director
and how did he get you on did he say he
was from david mamet's office
office yeah and they booked you on twin
pizzas i met the casting director and
she was like wonderful molly i want you
to meet david lynch and then they gave
me a part as a happy helping young lady
wow
you